[Music]
you know this crowd is off the charts
and I know you're used to this getting
used to this kind of attention I said in
the audience once you said in the
audience of a talk show
yes how long ago was this mmm late 90s
late 90s I think so no no it doesn't
matter I said in it that's the point
yeah doesn't really matter you sat in
that talk show audience one time what
yen did you enjoy the experience
well well first well he kept throwing us
Jolly Ranchers to keep our sugar levels
high but I don't do that we give
everyone a Cadillac when the show is
over look under your chairs look under
your chairs disappointed cuz I want it
to be like when I sat in the audience I
figured that I know that you're probably
want to see the guest but you probably
really want to get on camera too right
yeah can we bring somebody up
[Applause]
we don't do this well okay what is what
is your name my name is Linda Linda
where you from Linda
Westminster okay Westminster Westminster
California now make her tell you about
Gangster Squad how can I get a little
tip yeah okay give her a tip okay I feel
like it's going well I think that there
needs to be a little tension like a
little conflict okay ask you a question
so you say you're from Westminster or is
that a nice town I like I like your suit
did they make it for men
[Applause]
no they don't
well so nice having you here have you
been to a taping of this show before
once Oh
I think mr. Gosling had lined for you go
ahead you had a big mouth and you just
let your in it most possible interview
I've ever taken part in who the hell do
you think you are I hid blame you well
you know we're gonna talk about Gangster
Squad now you excited about this yeah we
have a clip here what can you tell us
about the clip
well Ryan's in it
well says here Ryan's nothing which
shows the one scene that Ryan's not in
from gangsters blood anything else we
need to know about this just wants to be
near Ryan is anatomically incorrect what
my bobblehead is anatomically correct
[Applause]
you're never coming back this was going
so well with Ryan and you come up here
with your hey and your anger you sicken
me
alright we have a clip here from
Gangster Squad should we throw to this
now okay let's all take a look mine to
business we'll get to you in a minute we
just want to talk the words all hey we
got a message for mr. Cohen look I don't
just seems like the lady doesn't want to
talk to you
well lady she just want to make these
postcards that Val
[Music]
where is it what is that is that your
message is that acid huh I swear that I
ever see you never again I'll kill you
[Applause]